today 500 million years ago aerobic
metabolism sits at the forefront of the
most efficient way to use energy and so
anything outside of aerobic metabolism
becomes anaerobic so if I don't have
that process that conversion of energy
I'll default very simply and we should
to this higher stress situation of using
energy so anaerobic doesn't necessarily
become a training process it's more or
less the byproduct of I'm no longer able
to handle aerobic Li what's going on so
how quickly I can come back to that
aerobic is literally how well I can so
having a very high aerobic capacity
means I function high aerobic Li so when
we look at people like a guy smashing
the two hour marathon what does he look
like physiologically and although
there's like look to be totally on
I support and I'm very happy for the man
and everything but realistically if he
were in the same setup as they were in
nineteen fifty or even nineteen eighty
he wouldn't have run a sub two hour
marathon
I'm joined by Brian Mackenzie the man
behind power speed endurance and today
we are talking about something that you
will all be familiar with but probably
doing a little bit wrong breathing Brian
welcome to the show thanks for having me
it's gonna be awesome and really excited
to speak about this stuff today we've
been talking about endurance a lot
recently had Alex Hutchinson write for
runners world on analyzing that you'd
capture gaez recent performance we've
had the Brian Carroll from power axe
strength on talking about squatting over
a thousand pounds and all of this is
enabled by a lot of different things but
I guess principally one of those is
breath work right yeah while physiology
and all chemistry is regulated through
our breath so anything and everything I
mean I've known Alex for quite some time
we've kind of gone we've gone back and
forth over the years he's a great
[ __ ] kid man I like him a lot
I don't know your other the other guy
but to squat a thousand pounds is to
understand some things understand some
things I mean Kelly Starrett we just
released an episode with him today we've
had dr. Stu McGill on so you know we've
had a lot of these guys and when they
when they talk about this even you know
Kelly and and Stu people that are really
really kind of at the the top of their
game very well respected within their
fields rather I hear someone bring up
breath work why do you think that Kelly
Kelly didn't Kelly didn't know we were
talking a bit about the game changes
we're talking about the game changes
documentary and veganism we went off on
a rabbit hole down there oh really
yeah no I know Kelly's very much into
the breath work at this point I mean I
introduced it to him so you know I know
he and he uses it inside of his 101 and
102 courses now so you know from his
work but you know in any rate Kelly's
been a very close compadre of mom I'm
for a very long time so we've kind of
grown up at me in - Heather but you know
it's interesting
how I stumbled onto to breathwork and
why even though I was introduced to it
quite some time ago and it just didn't
take and and I understand why I didn't
take because it wasn't never explained
in a way that made sense to especially a
guy who was participating in strength
and conditioning was all about
performance yeah I understand so IIIi
entered into this world of yoga many
years ago and had a yoga practice
because I was a triathlete who was
getting tight and when you get tight you
need to loosen up so I went to yoga and
I ended up enjoying yoga real like a ton
and I chased around a yogi in Astana
that was really good at what she was
doing but I just never paid attention to
the fact that we were in we were
utilizing a breath practice at the
foundation of this practice like we were
controlling our breeding we were told to
control our breathing we're told to
control our breathing in specific
patterns you know this went on and on
and I was like you know I just remember
it blowing over to a large degree and
that in and of itself is kind of how we
all behave to a large degree and I'll
connect all this through this talk so
like so that it makes sense for
everybody else um you know but I largely
just paid attention to the fact that I
needed to get more flexible or more
mobile at the time and then I drifted
away from yoga for a little bit really
got hardcore into endurance training
obviously wrote a couple books on that
and came to a pretty good understanding
of some ways to tweak things for people
who were busy and who were injured you
know and that that was a big part of my
career for about 10 or 12 years and then
somebody handed me a training mask and I
laughed and I was like this doesn't
change altitude I know how pressure
works I've actually worked on altitude
training for quite some time and this
can't change pressure pressure so we're
not talking about altitude with this
thing and but nonetheless you know when
you you make funnest
something and if you're in you know done
enough work in your life to understand
that that you haven't if you're making
fun of things or your courage to
criticizing things that you've never
done
that's called ignorance and I didn't
want to remain ignorant to something so
I put the damn thing on and I instantly
went from like I'm seated now to I sat
up and I engaged my diaphragm and I felt
my ribs expand out and like my back
light up and like I was like whoa like
you know was it was just I I tend to
feel a lot and because of my background
in teaching movement and getting people
fixed or helping people to fix
themselves I am you know I was just like
whoa here whoa what happened
like maybe we've got something that I
could put on my athletes when they're
warming up so that we can get them
moving properly and using their you know
their core correctly organizing their
spine in a way that it should be because
oh [ __ ] like it just so happens that we
organize the spine based on our
diaphragm we have to at the at the root
of who we are in what we do is a system
that is dependent upon one thing and
that is life and that life is predicated
on a deal that was made 500 million
years ago in order to use aerobic
metabolism so suffocation sits at the
heart of that so we could remove our
amygdala our panicked our freaked out or
not our panic center our fear center and
you will still have chemo receptors that
will set you off in a panic when carbon
dioxide levels raise so if I'm not
organized correctly around my spine I
don't use my diaphragm correctly so I
default into poor breathing patterns so
this is a rabbit hole of movement that
really made more sense to something
about organization of the spine right
and there's a there's a lot of minutiae
around the spine and organization and
core stability and everything we want to
do but by and large we have figured out
and theorized that the only reason you
need to organize that's fine correctly
is to actually take a breath
and or understand that breath because
the lungs don't do that work on their
own the diaphragm is the primary in that
and then we follow up to the
intercostals and several other muscles
that end up getting involved but poor
breathing a turn patterns elicit poor
responses including that of the
sympathetic nervous system or I default
into some poor breeding patterns that
have me using my anaerobic system more
than necessary and is that a nun dose so
I guess yes that is without exercise my
friend Wow
you are constantly using anaerobic
systems and aerobic systems at all times
we all wear we're like this is we know
this the what we started seeing was like
look man we took a look back so with
this started with a training mask it
inevitably became like oh [ __ ] you've
got your own training mask on your face
it's called a nose and holy crap it like
it has this filter system it's got these
this humidification system
it's got oh my gosh this thing mucus oh
it releases like immune cells like so it
helps my immune system function better i
I spin the air differently it forces my
diaphragm to actually pull more because
it's it's not allowing for fast air to
happen it doesn't mean we can't breathe
through our mouths or shouldn't
it's just when is it necessary and we
can get into that in a bit if you want
but you know it's interesting but we we
started understanding we started looking
at the physiology behind all of this
stuff and the framework behind
physiology and we've missed some big big
things and it's all there it's just way
we've taught it in a way we've looked at
it has not been real I would say it it's
not a very creative process thus why
it's eluded us and even in the world of
yoga today they've missed it and they've
missed understood what it is that
pranayama actually means in pranayama is
a word that is basically it's a Sanskrit
word it's probably about 5,000 years old
and there's other languages that use
this these very similar term
knowledge including Hebrew that it means
energy control at its root it also means
breath control odd that they're the same
odd that we use a cardio metabolic
device in order to measure our breath
which tells us what's happening from a
cellular level so cellular respiration
we understand the only way we can met we
measure that is through the gas exchange
of what's going on here so we said let's
look at this realistically and see what
happens and so we started measuring
things and we were measuring things in
many different ways including just a
simple breath practice or hey I'm gonna
go for a walk I'm gonna walk my dog and
Rob Wilson who's my counterpart in the
art of breath who's our lead on
education he's our director of education
went for a walk with his dogs with his
mouth open and then he came back reset
his device and we have portable
metabolic carts and he shut his mouth
and went for a walk with his dogs the
exact same route turns out those are two
different and totally totally different
metabolic profiles weird and that it's
not weird it's it's this has been said
for thousands of years we're not
actually bringing we're not actually
saying things that you know are that
crazy but unfortunately they are crazy
in our world because there's so many
really really really smart scientific
people who we look to who've missed the
boat on a lot of this stuff and the
simplicity of it and it's not that
they're dumb or that they whatever it's
just we weren't really looking at this
and so we started really going after not
only the movement and and and and how
the mechanics work around this but then
the physiology right
um and then starting to see that oh wow
it's all chemistry in the body is
regulated through our breath all of it
so how we shift from alkaline to acidic
is literally governed through how I
breathe and how I absorb oxygen is
dependent upon how well my body actually
plays with this mala this this thing
called carbon dioxide and the body in
the blood it's carbonic acid and as
we exhale is a gas exchanges it becomes
carbon dioxide but I am largely
dependent upon how well I actually react
to that and that can you know that that
has other facets to it I'll go here in a
second but my relationship to carbon
dioxide is actually how well I play with
oxygen and how well I'm efficient how
efficient I am at using oxygen so I may
be a free diver who can actually sit
here and do breath work and be very very
very oxygen efficient because I can hold
my breath for long periods of time which
also requires in a very high level to
co2 tolerance this is static co2
tolerance this is non-working co2
tolerance when we look at training or we
look at human performance and I use
quotes because performance I think is
we're about to kind of shift the
paradigm on what human performance is
but the idea that if I work like when I
start to work out that shifts there's a
different response or there's a there's
a very different play that happens
within co2 tolerance and so I've been
I've been able to observe and take
people who are free divers who are
highly specialized or big wave surfers
who are also what you know free divers
in essence to some degree but they're
spa highly specialized and when we apply
work to them we see a very different
story happen so we see the specialist
kind of come apart right meaning there's
a very different like that co2 tolerance
that was really high when I'm static and
not a lot of stressors going on or a big
wave things like that I'm very
accustomed to when I start working out
my respiration rate goes up considerably
higher than it would with somebody let's
say let's call it you know
elio it right his respiration rate isn't
gonna go up so high right but the
interesting thing here is I would bet if
Ellie Woods never really participated in
any sort of static breathing or carbon
dioxide tolerance training
he's probably [ __ ] statically
right and so there's this weird world
that we started to see now my
fascination is in connection with the
brain and so the neurobiology of it and
the physiology i'm i'm i've consign ow
considering what physiology is more or
less our mind our ability that that's
what our mind is and our ability to
connect to the mind and understand the
feelings and the processes and the
things that are going on and so the
brain is where the circuitry and the
information is being sent out the brain
works perfectly fine as long as we're
connected to the physiology and
understand the physiology if we don't
understand the physiology the brain will
get away from us and start over thinking
right and so as kids when we come into
this world we have this thing where
we're attached to a parent and we learn
missus it's unavoidable right and so
from a neurobiological perspective at
the top layer the most evolved part of
the brain is our neocortex and this is
where the stories this is where some of
the emotional things like start to
trigger but this is where the
storytelling motor control a lot of
there's a lot of a dedicated area to
motor control on the brain to where we
can do different tasks like I can't aah
or like I can talk and drink water at
the same time or think and drink what
you know you know I mean I mean just a
simple basic [ __ ] that we go throughout
our day that some of us confuse
ourselves and thinking it's multitasking
of which it's not so that's the
storytelling side of things below that
becomes the limbic system this is where
emotions are now concrete and set up in
the system and where I will have a
reaction emotionally to something and
then the storytelling gets played into
there right and so it can get
exacerbated then down below that we have
the brainstem where or we could call it
the reptilian brain the oldest part of
the brain and this is where the kind of
evolution of everything takes place it
just so happens that our respiration
centers are set up in that brain stem so
meaning they are on autopilot with my
system and they can respond to every
emotion and every thought that I have it
also can respond to the work that I have
because
I have dedicated chemoreceptor set up in
the carotid and the aortic valves which
are headed out to the periphery so that
means we're on a prediction system that
carbon dioxide levels that are set up in
my brainstem react to a prediction of
what's occurring in the system through
chemo receptors and barrel receptors
that are in my arteries and it's
triggering me to breathe hmm so my heart
rate responds to that right so the heart
rates late to the game and so you know
there's a whole plethora of things in
there but how I decide to grow up and
how I go through my experiences in life
inevitably have a Rolodex of things on
how I actually respond to breath so when
I actually am working out
I can tell with many people where the
potential trauma or problems can set up
or we can see metabolic issues even from
somebody who doesn't work out as they
sit and are doing things I get yeah yeah
one thing that's just come to me that as
you were talking do you think it's
strange that we don't have control over
our heartbeat as humans as evolved
creatures well the only way you're gonna
control your heart rate is how output
movement nope breath you got it I'm just
thinking because I can so if I just said
hey Chris check it out control your
heart rate for me right now and if we
put you on a heartrate monitor
cuz that's what you we most people would
do they go I let me get on a heartrate
monitor like well no no no can you feel
your heartbeat right now without doing
anything can you feel it
a tiny weight I'd have to be very tuned
into my body yeah yeah yeah yeah took me
about about three years ago I was able
to like I can just sit there and I could
pick it up anywhere in my body I would
really want it or I want to do in a toe
or a finger or my neck or whatever right
but it's like all right how do I lower
that and I literally will go
and my heart rate would start to drop I
control my breathing I understand I
think that that obviously shows that the
heart rate is at the mercy of the breath
to a large degree hmm I was just
thinking about whether it's it's I can
control my breath I can consciously hold
it
breathe quicker breathe slower but
that's not something that we have with
our digestive system that's not
something that we have with our heart
you know that it would appear that from
our the things that are inside of us the
lungs are kind of the only thing that we
have that kind of control over is that
fair to say or am I missing something
that your your breath so check this out
this and this might flip your lid I'm
ready your breath your breath controls
all that okay rest and digest is
controlled by the breath bks I anger as
a quote he is responsible for bringing
yoga to the Western world he's one of
the last great Yogi's what now he also
taught things in a way that was fairly
brutal I would not have gone by where
real well today nonetheless uh I'm of
that school like I like that I don't
need to be coddled IIIi won't work
III want real work nonetheless the mind
is the king of the senses but the breath
is the king of the mind I like that okay
so that was his that's not mine my
breathing affects how I digest things
how so well my diaphragm pushes down
into my organs
I have regulation of my parrot III I
have regulation of my sympathetic
activity due to how I control my
breathing and the inhale is known as the
sympathetic and for a long time people
have said the exhale is known as
parasympathetic well it's not
parasympathetic it's inhibition of
sympathetic that's in trying that's what
HIV
love HIV stuff gets wrist monitors and
stuff would come from right it's the
variation within heartbeats yes yes yeah
and so the can we start figuring out a
long time ago that you could manipulate
heart rate variability through breath
control easy so you could change a
profile of an athlete who who might not
have the score or the readiness state
that we want right and we'd apply breath
work to that person and we could
manipulate and them they'd have a green
light
what's readiness States what what's the
characteristics that contribute to that
you fit into a specific profile so like
think of a spectrum like think think of
an arc right of sympathetic and
parasympathetic rise with him there's a
specific arc with her inside
parasympathetic and slightly in the
sympathetic that you can be in order to
be ready to train that let's call it
eighty percent and above right so we
would have if an athlete fell to
parasympathetic that meant that they
were literally you know your
dissociative you're shutting down type
of thing you need more up regulatory
things like cold plunge likes you know
things to kind of bring you up out of
that but from the city and there's a
there's a lot more to that but from a
more sympathetic side this is where most
of us tend to fall is where we just
aren't coming down enough we're not
coming out of that high sympathetic
activity that's by and large most of the
people I deal with and I see this is the
people who are probably listening to
hear the over train is overworked yeah I
like coffee I like to work out hard I
like to work hard I'm very passionate
about what I do I'm type a you know
maybe not so type a but I do like to
train hard and do things hard and do all
this and by and large what we end up
getting with those people is an
inability to understand actually what
they're training for like they you know
and this
why breathing's so important is because
I can actually get you to understand a
lot more through that process of
training and understanding your breath
it's also why we created a gear system
around training and how you can actually
manipulate the one variable that is
actually responsible for the rest of the
variables that you're training for mmm
yeah that is that is right and it does
make sense that you have this direct
control over one of the internal
processes that's going on we have a I
suppose a quite diluted control over the
thoughts that go through our mind but I
have a lot better control of my breath
and I do the thoughts in my mind and
that's after three years of pretty
consistent meditation so you know I
think I think dancing on the breath
seems like a good place to start so if
we were to do a breath mot Brian where
would you where would you start
if you lay someone down and gonna look
under the hood you're gonna look at the
way that they breathe either in or out
of a training situation where do you
start
is it the cycle is it actually co2
tolerance test III get a co2 tolerance
test down one and I'm a max exhale test
that tells me literally what's going
like I mean look
so Mike my Rob who I work with he's in
Virginia Beach which is like the largest
hub of Special Forces so Special Warfare
in the world it's really house seemed
six you know there's another team over
there too but there's a lot of
high-level dudes over there a lot of
Bob's yeah but these dudes like to train
a certain way too right and so you know
like you get these guys and and they've
got problems going on and it's like
alright you know Rob got called in
yesterday for no this morning we were on
the phone this morning it was his
afternoon and he said yeah I couldn't
finish training I got called in to go
over to this this place to go meet this
guy who seems to be a pretty problematic
and he's got a lot of issues and can't
recover he's got these injuries going on
and blah blah blah just there's a
hostess [ __ ] and he's a team guy and you
know he Rob went over and he's like
guess what a co2 tolerance level was
and I was like under 20 seconds and he
said 17 seconds and I was like yep get
it and you know he is cooked and most of
us are cooked if I've got somebody who's
training like that if I've got an
operator especially an operator who's
got anything under a minute of a co2
tolerance test I've got somebody who's
reactive I've got somebody who their
system is reactive they Mont may not be
emotionally reactive but there's
suppression of things I know that the
tissue isn't responding well meaning
they're tight they're probably got
painful tissue like these things start
to like compound right and they're all
signs like so carbon dioxide is the
metabolic stress messenger of the body
of the system don't even need an
amygdala man you know so it tells me
what's going on with the person so if I
it's like when I have too much going on
upstairs I push that co2 tolerance down
right if I'm over trained if I've been
training too much and I haven't let my
body recover enough I'm pushing that co2
tolerance level down when I think when I
do too much I'm pushing that co2
tolerance level down meaning when co2
raises it doesn't have to raise as much
in order for me to react to it respond
to it and the first respondent of that
is your breath because I have to offload
that co2 in order to feel better so my
aerobic efficiency capacity threshold
whatever switch is based on how much how
well I tolerate co2 it's also telling me
what basically is going to be happening
cognitively so if I get a person the
first thing I'm doing with them most
likely is a co2 tolerance test to tell
me exactly where they're at it's a
three-fold test so I we you sit down for
a couple minutes or you lay down for a
couple minutes and you just do some slow
controlled breathing that you're
comfortable with not fast you can't
hyperventilate then we go into a four
breath
where we breathe up for like three three
or four seconds and then you relax let
it go for about five to seven you know
five seconds or so so it's a little bit
longer than exhale but let's relax let
it go then inhale forth breath you pull
it in start the timer the moment hits
the top of the breath and you start
exhaling as long and as slow as you
possibly can so you have to control it
so there's a three-part test and it
tells me how much control you have of
your diaphragm on the negative how well
I have control of that so there's the
mechanical aspect of it right then from
a physiological perspective it tells me
how well you how well your physiology is
responding to carbon dioxide
so how aerobic ly efficient you're going
to be just calm okay remember the dog
walking the dog story how how well do
you respond in a very simple fashion to
carbon dioxide cognitively so from a
state perspective and arousal state
perspective how what you how you react
to carbon dioxide so the panic switch so
when you're going to be reactive how
you're going to be reactive anybody
below twenty seconds and we have a very
reactive volatile environment that we
need to actually start working to clean
up and that's usually done fairly
quickly with most people if and only if
they're willing to actually back off a
bit and learn that allows for a gap to
start to occur an improvement to start
to cure and the co2 tolerance so then we
start to administer some breathing
protocols hey let's figure out and this
is why we built the state app was so
that we could actually get people some
protocols to use to actually work on
breath control to increase their co2
tolerance but also allow them to kind of
get into this more focused or calm clear
state or downshift them prior to after
training or prior to bed that was the
whole point and so we'll set protocols
up for people based on where they need
the most help
how much of the breath control that
we're talking about there is simple
ability to avoid discomfort because
someone who is in a good place who might
feel like I can control this gasp reflex
for longer that will contribute a little
bit but as you've mentioned as well the
co2 this co2 tolerance appears to be
like the master of this is that right
yeah so what's the question might
rephrase your bringing that it back
again so how much can be trained in
terms of someone's ability to breathe
that is separate to the way that their
physiology has put together at that time
so is this someone who's very good at
controlling their breath what still
might be in there yeah so that that's
that's the interesting thing and this is
why this is where my work really
diverted because I was running around
with guys like wim ha I was literally
pretty close with wim HOF and there's
nothing like women's got a great thing
he's doing great work you know there's
other like I've gone and participated
and learned about to mow many of the you
know yogic practices etc etc holotropic
like the Buteyko like there's a lot of
methods out there right and
unfortunately each and one each and
every one of these methods is making
claims that it doesn't do in some
fashion in some fashions they do in
other fashions and this is the problem
with you know getting caught up in yeah
and understanding our attachments to
things and you know thinking that you
know we've got an answer and the answer
is you you're the answer you're the only
answer there is it's not your breathing
your breeding is not an answer either
it's just an indicator of something
right and so our ability biologically is
is is not even close to being tapped and
I I think that be true even with
something like you know what happened
with Elliot but going back to this is
it's I started seeing that not everybody
reacts to the same protocols in the same
way and so it became a there is not a
one size fit all fits all there's a you
know there's a more or less kind of a
fingerprint some degree and although we
can
get people and categorize them in
specific ways or you know things that
are going on like hey this guy is angry
about stuff and that guy is angry about
stuff and she's angry about stuff and
you know she's more emotional and he's
more emotional about things like meaning
depending on how you emotionally handle
things there are gonna be certain
patterns that are gonna set certain
things off and connect you to certain
things so we had just I had to start I
was literally running around
fingerprinting people with breath breath
protocols because not everybody was
responding the same way and that wasn't
a very you know viable thing for helping
people I was sir I was helping specific
people but I was burning myself out and
there's no way I was ever gonna be able
to do this by myself so build an app and
build an algorithm that worked with that
we understood how to do that
so we literally customized things to
people but then it's like okay well a
lot of these people like to engage in
performance and they should because you
should have a movement practice any
human being that does not have a
movement practice is not being a human
being we are designed to move now
getting neurotic about that to the
degree that like I have to be this
specific thing or whatever that that's
where it gets crazy but nonetheless
applying this inside of movement the
framework of movement becomes the next
catalyst and how we do things and the
base layer of that is hey for the first
few weeks we're gonna just be nasal
breathing you can't go anything past
nasal breathing and for most people
that's such a kick in the balls it's
like I don't want to do it like my ego
is not ready for that check and you know
you take a power lifter that squats a
thousand pounds I can tell you right now
if they've not done any breath work
their co2 tolerance is [ __ ] that's a
massive massive carbon print you're
carrying so much lean muscle so much
muscle but you don't do you know most of
these people don't do enough of the kind
of aerobic efficiency work and and
that's a scary word to guys like that
and gals because they think that they
they're scared of a row and it's like
that's not what I'm talking about what
I'm talking about is the thing that
actually makes you survive like a row
big metabolism is what makes you survive
so when you're resting you should be
high level aerobic and yet you see these
guys and gals on oxygen tanks and like
breathing like and that's that's not
necessary it's not and and it's not
healthy
what indication let's let you to see
poor co2 tongs okay and that is
exacerbated by people who are high mass
I muscle mass heavy weight it's a car
here look look look what's the demand
for oxygen with more muscle mass it's up
higher so I need more oxygen or because
like look like you know so I've got all
this tissue well when I don't have
enough oxygen or I'm not efficient
enough about four or five breaths in
you're gonna start dipping that needle
more towards those anti-roll a like more
towards the the demand for the tissues
demand for more glucose more glycogen
okay the nervous system and brain are
stuck with glucose and glycogen there's
no there's no if and buts about that
right but fat is what the muscles like
can use so the more fat we're using with
with tissue the better right and so the
better we get the mitochondria
functioning the better off we are and
there's no reason why and enough
alignment and a gymnast or an endurance
athlete can't all be aerobic ly
efficient it's just different thresholds
at which point like sure the foot
lineman is gonna be much more of an
anaerobic athlete like much more high
levels you know you know sprinter type
explosive you know and so is the gymnast
to some degree is you know pulling it
back a little bit more and then it's
like we got the endurance athlete where
you're like you know all slow-twitch
right and it's all the same thing in
terms of efficiency aerobic lee it's
like so if I got it if I've got an
endurance athlete who's going out on a
high level aerobic ride but they got to
open their mouth I can tell you right
now they're not is row because they
could be they might be somewhat aerobic
but they are
not as aerobic as they could be and they
are not utilizing the system in a way
that they could with it this is
literally factual things we have tested
that are now going into read that did
have raised some eyebrows enough to go
wow we didn't really look at it like
this we should really be testing this so
this is what's happening I get it so
let's take it from the top with regards
to Brian's advice for good breath why do
we begin we have what what are the
principles for good breath the state app
was created for this like look starting
them do one one breath protocol exercise
in the morning do one in the evening for
sleep play with that for a few weeks see
where it improves what you feel how you
what what you like what you don't you
want to play with more go for it right
that's probably gonna be in the vicinity
of five minutes each right that's not
hard for people who like to Train
moaning any of secondarily morning and
evening right simple if you want to do
all four go for it
do it like you're you're getting an A+
now um the second part of this is if
you're not going to the World
Championships or you're not competing
for you know an Olympic medal or you're
not like going to an a priority race
within the next two months you do not or
event you do like there's no reason why
you can't go dedicate three to four
weeks to strictly nasal only breathing
and take enough step back to actually
get your physiology rewired across all
across all learning methodologies
whether you cross all training a
powerlifter CrossFit whatever I've done
it with the CrossFit athletes I did it
with TIA
like I've done it with like I've done it
with several [ __ ] athletes that
people would never consider what would
be able to do something like this and it
rearranged what was going on and gave
them an ability to do things that they
didn't think they could make they could
manage to do
so it just empowered them in a level
yeah yeah well I mean how long does it
take to create adaptation to something
right around three weeks I like it I
like that of course everyone he was
listening to stay up will be linked in
the show notes below Brian's up which I
pretty certain is this the first
iteration or is it on to kind of at one
point five now what's the app yes this
is the first version there's been a
couple updates on it yes but this is the
first version of it we're there's a lot
more that's gonna come into the pipeline
and once we get through the first
investor stuff that we're going through
there will be some serious serious
things that are coming down that
pipeline you know I mean it's already
been way more successful than we ever
thought it was gonna be but we also know
like there's a lot more that we do than
just doing some simple breath protocols
like there's high level things you can
do in order to change your physiology
that could you know that are game
changing things mmm
so what happens when you brief yeah who
knows tell me someone's training that
just breathing through their nose what's
happening what's what's the we've talked
about the different workout of the walk
with the dog yeah nose open and closed
what how is that characterized it's your
biological way of staying aerobic you
five hundred million years ago cells
single-cell organisms figured out how to
become multicellular organisms they said
hey let's you and I communicate like you
and I are right now let's talk about
some things let's share some information
so we can pass this [ __ ] on and see that
see that oxygen-rich environment now it
used to be hostile
it used to be mostly carbon like it
wasn't we had to be anaerobic and we you
changed energy other ways and this is
where like we're headed right now is
this is all about energy there's nothing
else there's nothing
else other than energy all energy that's
ever existed has existed it's how where
can the conversion of energy is
happening we don't it's not we burnt we
don't burn calories okay that that's us
we're converting calories we're
literally taking energy converting that
energy and then putting energy back out
like it's literally this cycle of and we
forget about all of this thing and so
that energy deal got made when cells
learned to communicate and said hey
let's take this oxygen and let's use
this and it's much more complex than
this but this is just the story that I
like you know like but it's like hey 500
million years ago multicellular
organisms figured out how to use oxygen
after algae and algae literally figured
out how to convert sunlight into energy
itself and the byproduct of that was
oxygen so the earth became engulfed in
this algae all the sudden there's all
this oxygen in the environment then
cells are like yo there's got to be an
efficient process to this and here's
that process today 500 million years ago
aerobic metabolism sits at the forefront
of the most efficient way to use energy
and so anything outside of aerobic
metabolism becomes anaerobic so if I
don't have that process that conversion
of energy I'll default
very simply and we should to this higher
stress situation of using energy so
anaerobic doesn't necessarily become a
training process it's more or less the
byproduct of I'm no longer able to
handle aerobic Li what's going on so how
quickly I can come back to that aerobic
is literally how well I can so having a
very high aerobic capacity means I
function high aerobic Li so when we look
at people like a guy smashing the two
hour marathon what does he look like
physiologically and although there's
like look to be totally on
I support and I'm very happy for the man
and everything but realistically if he
were in the same setup as they were in
nineteen fifty or even nineteen eighty
he wouldn't have run a sub two hour
marathon
that wouldn't it's not the same marathon
it's a different marathon even though
the distances are the same the shoes the
Pacers the the the all of these things
exist but I don't deny the fact that
this man's physiology is off the hook
and the only reason I really know that
is not only if I studied how he moves
but I've watched how he breathes
what's your analysis of I'm Meryl is
your analysis of it he primarily
breathes through his nose okay most of
his marathon is done nose only breathing
you can find pictures all over the
internet with salt marks that come down
his nose and you'll see when he's
running that most of the pictures of him
with his mouth shut
hmm I didn't notice oh I've watched
video yeah yeah well I've done video
I've got videoed the video so that I
could go and slow it down and look at it
and watch it you know I painted that and
there it is and you know I mean he comes
from African culture right and and what
what is of the African nose like they've
got larger nostrils well they've like
genetically they're set up to do
something like if you've ever watched a
horse race so I watched an i watch
animals like like it's like big passion
like I'm almost neurotic about it you
know you watch animals who don't sweat
and they don't actually the only time
their mouth breathing is when they're
overheating okay you watch animals who
do sweat a horse a racing horse
they will not breathe out of their
mouths they just have a bit in their
mouth they breathe through their
nostrils they literally will not breathe
out of their mouth why do we then
because we you know it's interesting we
have done real well at progressing
ourselves culturally through comfort and
convenience and in that process we've
more or less stressed ourselves more
than we actually needed to so by that I
mean this
there was a book written in 1867 I
believe I forget the date but George
Caitlin wrote a book called shut your
mouth and save your life
and he wrote this book as a historian
who was a lawyer from England who came
over to the States which was basically
North America and South America at the
time
studied about a million and a half
indigenous cultures and civilized world
he was the biggest thing he picked up on
was the fact that in did an indigenous
culture they did not breathe through
their mouths rarely when and when they
taught when they spoke they spoke with
intent they did not speak too much they
meant what they said they said what they
meant when they slept they slept with
their mouths shut when they hunted they
hunted with their mouths shut they did
everything they could including when
children came off of the nipple mothers
would shut the mouth of the child for
fear of the black mouth because not only
was the white eye called the white eye
or round eye he was called the black
mouth and the reason he was called black
mouth is because his mouth looked
disgusting and why would that be well
look at what we started doing culture
look what we started doing I mean we're
drinking more alcohol we were sugar
started to become agriculture started to
kick in all of these things of
convenience started to happen right and
here's a culture of people who play
attention to nature what is nature
physiology that is literally one of the
definitions of the nature of physiology
is nature origin and thus paying
attention to the feelings of nature and
what's going on so what happens when I
feel when I breathe through my mouth
right well I get ramped up I turn on I
speak if I go speak somewhere and I talk
just for an hour I'm on like I feel like
I'm on if I speak for an entire day I'm
exhausted I don't go work out I try not
to go to dinner with people afterwards
why am I so exhausted I'm blowing off a
ton of car
knocks I'm more sympathetic dominant I'm
actually using less of the fat so I'm
using I'm not as aerobic as I could be
even though I'm still slightly aerobic
I'm not as a robe because I could be
right so it's learning those waves they
felt that [ __ ] man they felt it we don't
feel we have we have these things in
front of us and we're getting stimulated
we've got all these kids that are going
batshit crazy because they don't have
recess anymore they're cold from playing
they're told what to do they're told how
they're gonna learn then they're given
infinite possibilities on a machine to
play games and keep them occupied
because mom and dad don't want to deal
with them and then they've got anxiety
because of this they don't have anxiety
they've got proper stimulation from
being overstimulated they've got
physiology that's run amok and they
don't understand it and this is by and
large that what's going on with us even
those of us that like to Train a lot
like I mean I'm on I'm talking to you
I'm on I need to [ __ ] when I'm done here
I mean I'm feeling this I feel it so
I've gotten to the point where I feel
all this stuff and I'm paying attention
if my mouth opens when I'm asleep at
night I wake up why why would I wake up
if my mouth opens I taste on everything
we I've just kind of gone over because
you become less stressed bingo I'm now
slipping more into sympathetic and I'm
finding myself on mmm okay I understand
how many of us are trying to sleep in
this high sympathetic activity state
right and I'm also not as aerobic and
then oh [ __ ] I've got sleep apnea so now
I'm holding my breath in an awkward
fashion like I've got all like weird
like what are you paying it's like you
need medication and a [ __ ] you need a
mask to wear at night I've got friends
who do this and they refuse to do breath
work and I'm like dude it's your choice
hmm
I've got more dm's and pee I don't even
talk about this I don't write about this
stuff publicly like I don't go out and
go I'm gonna solve your problems no here
start with some breathing protocols
start rearranging your training then
start
what's going on in your body you're
gonna default to places that you can is
it weird that George Caitlin was also in
a book that I've read and the I'm the
only person who's caught this so far
right only because I've read this other
book it's a book called empire of the
summer moon and it is about the Comanche
Indians who are arguably the most war
driven tribe of people that have almost
existed there they're in comparison to
the bongos and like um you know a lot of
the stuff that happened them but they
were very very gnarly they were so
gnarly that had the Colt revolver not
ended up in the hands of a few young
white boys from Texas called Texas
Rangers they would have this world this
country would be a very different place
right now
they knew how to fight off of horseback
in a way that no other culture had
understood and they couldn't combat it
so shooting a rifle with one shot was no
good right and so this book was written
and there was a guy around there was a
number of historians that were there
that were interviewed and one of those
historians throughout this book that was
written about was George Caitlin and so
there's this guy that's there and the
biggest thing he picked up on was that
the people who were of the of the earth
that were literally living on the earth
that we're living in planes that
everybody feared to cross because they
had no idea how to navigate they had no
idea how to do things and there was this
murderous culture of people who did not
want them near anything including other
tribes like other tribes feared the
Comanche right like they were feared and
it's a fantastic read but the fact of
the matter is is I'm able to now connect
through reading physiology and then
reading about literally hey George
Caitlin wrote this book in the 6th and
1800s about this holy crap there it is
what is history it's literally telling
us what's going on like there's lessons
to be learned about all this stuff and
what people were doing you think you
think a Comanche
Indian who knew how to navigate the land
could get on his horse and ride for
three or four days straight with no food
basically or limited food supply and
water supply what do you think the
physiology of a human being like that is
like literally could survive in
freezing-cold temperatures navigate land
and storms like where do you think we're
at culturally right now we're worried
about squatting a thousand pounds and
running a two hour marathon I don't
think we're anywhere close to what our
biological potential is I think we
missed the boat
I think we're confused I think we think
that technology is this great thing
that's gonna get us into the future and
it's not it's gonna just gonna lead us
right back to our own biology and going
[ __ ]
we're mimicking all this technology
after stuff we internally are able to do
it's why I asked you what would you what
what's your how do you control your
heart rate and how do you feel that well
I'd have to be calm for a minute and
then I could really pick up on yeah well
guess what you can feel that at any
moment you want just got to spend the
time to get back to that I understand
yeah it's interesting what you said
there about when you spend a whole day
talking right so I do coaching class I
coach a yes sales company in Germany and
every time I'm doing let's say it's
maybe three hours and I've been talking
to these guys and it's a conversation
it's at least 50/50 between me and them
it's not all me but once I'm finished
let's serve them three hours four hours
of talking a little bit of water in
between a little bit of chill or
whatever after I've done that I'm
absolutely gassed like once I'm done I'm
like I'm really tired and I wasn't
really sure I thought well maybe it's
because it cognitively it's quite
demanding I'm trying to link these
things together it's because I'm really
putting myself into the person I'm
speaking to or whatever it might be and
your suggestion here is that one of the
principal reasons for this is going to
be that I'm just inhaling and exhaling
quite a bit of air quite a lot well your
breathe yeah yeah you're on right and so
you're getting stimulated but you're
getting a stimulation that you're
automatically like you're falling into
autopilot on because you're talking I'm
talking right so where I'm ramping
myself up not only my ramp myself up and
getting
what I'm doing I'm getting focused and
I'm being engaged with you but the
byproduct of that becomes my breath my
breath is the instant reaction to that
it's it's the first respondent there's
only two two things we can do in order
to regulate or stimulate autonomic
control consciously that is our breath
in our vision so I can choose not to
look at you right now and I can look at
the end of the room and I can go into
peripheral vision I can downshift myself
I can go outside and look at the [ __ ]
look at nature look at trees right how
many people freaked out looking at a
sunset
none of them why because it's math no
it's beautiful yeah beautiful is there
but that's not math math is the
algorithm that enters the light waves
that enter your eyes and open you up to
go womp and it drops you into
parasympathetic it's interesting we've
got so many tools and things going on
that we don't know about like a later
man I was just the Cleveland Clinic I
was an open heart surgery with them with
a team there and they were like what do
you think he could help with and it's
like simple man control your breathing
and control your vision when you need to
when you need to make a better decision
or something [ __ ] the [ __ ] hits the
fan like it's time to do that
that's human performance the human
performance at its finest and trying to
help somebody's life be saved you know
and like why'd that person get there is
another [ __ ] another story that we could
be dovetailing back towards hey why we
move and what we love about human
performance but that's human performance
for me like human performance is
literally getting to the core of why you
know people doing everyday stuff right
like that's human performance and I
think we're eluding ourselves into
thinking that we understand something by
you know like what's a 500 pound
deadlift do for me
these were things I had to ask myself
right like this isn't I'm not asking
this of you I'm and ask this of myself
what's a 500 pound dead because I've had
a 500 pound deadlift right and it's like
I I was not able to connect the dots on
what that meant I don't
oh that that made it better for me to
survive getting up off the couch or
picking [ __ ] up off the floor I don't
know that that 500 pounds is necessary
for that like what's running a hundred
miles doing for me it was a [ __ ]
amazing experience but what was it doing
for me right like where was I at and so
what why you know do I need to actually
run a harm ah no but will I
I mean sure I did a couple times but you
know like it's just like I've done these
things and I'm like so what's the point
of this is this oh I'm now clinging to
this thing thinking it's the thing and
there we go now the mind now now let's
look at the let's look at the
neuroscience let's let's let's really
start looking at the down the up the how
everything's compiling and what I'm
doing and why I'm doing it so when I ask
people like what do you want because
they'll come to me I literally have a
call after this with our mentorship
program and I've already had two today
and it's what do you want and I'm pretty
quick to understand that they don't know
what they want even though they're
telling me what they want and so it's
usually like tell me what you want I'll
show you a liar because we're just not
ready really ready let go of all these
ideas that we have and it's nothing
can't go deadlift thousand pound or you
know whatever
you can't squat a thousand deadlift 500
go around a hundred miles like these are
just extreme versions of them right I
don't need to go dive with great white
sharks but I did and I got that
experience and it taught me some
profound lessons man profound but if I'm
actually in the moment and understanding
what's going on in this very moment and
how I'm operating and what I feel then
I'm moving back more towards what that
command she was doing and I'm actually
getting in tune with the vibration of
how everything works and why when I go
well I you know I went on a run earlier
what I'm trying to accomplish for that
run and understand about that run where
is it that on this hill that I'm
climbing right now that I have to that I
feel like I need to make this switch and
how like how cook do I feel and where is
that at and what can I do in order to
improve that so that like hey this this
improves my day and it doesn't ruin my
day
right that's what I'm caught you know
this is where we start to my reactions
to what I'm doing in training my
reactions to what I'm doing throughout
my day are the same thing but I'm just
getting people closer to what that
actually is and that's what we've been
doing with the art of breath is really
just you know like people come in there
and like you know this gala this weekend
who has showed up at Rob's seminar she
was like she's a CrossFit Games athlete
and you know she identified as a
CrossFit Games athlete I love that like
I just love somebody comes in I'm like a
professional athlete prosthetics like
Wow
okay I get it I know where you're at you
know we're doing all this work and stuff
and there's a hypoxic set where you do
farmer carries with with kettlebells
right so like you'll do some burpees and
then you go and you have people grab the
kettlebells and then they dump their air
and they have to walk as far as they can
down and back
okay just follow and it's in it yeah and
so everybody like this chick just takes
off running man hmm like she's trying to
win it you know and one of our coaches
Danny Jaeger who's phenomenal and he
runs cross at King field out in
Minnesota and he's like he watches this
and then he sees a bunch of guys so
there's a lot of people there in the
warfare community so there's a lot of
you know dudes and people who are like
want to win right it's like what are you
trying to win so Danny stop it he goes
hey if you think we brought you here to
actually see how long you could hold
your breath while Farmar walking
kettlebells
you don't understand why you're here you
don't understand what we're doing what
is it you're feeling when you're holding
your breath and walking these things
what's if you're trying to win the
farmer carry holding your breath what is
it you're winning here there is no
reward it's we're here to experience
something and understand what this thing
can do and teach us well I thought I was
gonna be able to carry those kettlebells
a lot further or I thought I was only
going to be able to carry em
few steps and I went further than I did
awesome now we're starting to get
somewhere versus oh I gotta win this
like win what
what are we winning that's called ego
and and you just removed yourself from
understanding all purposes of training
all training at the foundation of
training is to make better decisions
under stress carbon dioxide is the
metabolic stress messenger of the human
body done deal I love it I love it Brian
today's being fantastic I really
appreciate you coming on anyone who
wants to check out some more of your
work where should they head we've talked
about out of breath how does that relate
to the stay up is to stay up a part of
that doesn't separate now stay - bit bit
different the state apps separate you
know a lot of the stuff at the business
is gonna change real soon in fact the
whole name everything's gonna change
we're changing that so it all kind of
fit and be seamless so it makes more
sense to the world that being said the
art of breath is a component of what we
teach with inside of power speed
endurance it's a performance based
seminar there's a 101 that we teach
around the world but we also have it
online so that can be found on power
speed endurance the state app is you can
find each app whether it's Android or
iOS on shift state dot IO anything about
me or if you want to get in contact with
me or you know whatever can be found on
Brian Mackenzie comm or you can go
through power speed endurance amazing I
have to say it was a listener who
recommended that I check out the state
and get in touch with yourself and I
think I've found the new thing I'm gonna
add into my morning and evening routine
I've been looking for what it's going to
be I've stopped doing ROM WOD for the
time being and I do miss some of the
breath control I missed that
parasympathetic activation I'm still
doing my meditation on the morning I'm
reading I'm doing other bits and pieces
Stu Miguel's big three but I'm not I'm
not feeling myself in the body quite so
much with that it's very it's very
visceral it's very kind of trance
that I'm doing it for the further return
on on what I know it needs to do to my
spine health and I think yeah I think
the next I think the between now and
Christmas it'll be it'll be me doing
that so I'll report back I'll keep you
updated to please do yeah look at like I
I would do the either feel alert or be
present protocol if you're if you're
still doing your meditation in the
morning do the breathing beforehand
there's a reason why breathing is at the
foundation of every meditative practice
that's interesting so you'd say a lot of
people that are listening maybe we'll
have a meditative practice in the
morning routine you'd say do the breath
work before that and then how do you
program that and evening if you have
yeah if you have an active sitting
meditative practice just be clear that
if you want that brought up to the next
level add breathing before that if you
want it really brought up to the next
level use the state app so that you can
fingerprint your the rhythms that work
with you like so your apps different
gonna be different than mine
based on - you know how you actually
handle carbon dioxide cognitive and how
you handle emotional stress so that can
give you an a ramp in I can't tell you
how many people who come to me who are
like I can't meditate it's just I don't
have the patience I don't have this I
don't have that you're already there but
it's like I show them breathing and the
fact is is breathing is controlled
breathing is meditation
literally you'll get there
it just give it some time right so use
that beforehand in the evening anything
less than two hours before you go to bed
okay using the smallest sleep protocol
that'll downshift you and change the
sleep you should probably see some
increases definitely in deep sleep but
also potentially in the REM cycle
fantastic I've also got my new whoop
band coming as the last one is as lapsed
so we'll actually be able to track that
and see if that's making any difference
as well which would be which would be
interesting but Brian today's been
absolutely awesome to the people that
are listening you already know what to
do the links to everything that we've
spoken about the stay app shift state IO
power
speed endurance and Brian's website will
be linked in the show notes below go
hassle him online if if you need to get
some more info of him
but Brian it's been it's been fantastic
man I'm really looking forward to
getting into my breath work right on
Chris thanks for having me man
[Music]